Hey everyone.  We've seen how incentive misalignment causes issues between divisions and the firm.
And this arose due to the profit and cost center misalignment coordination costs and attention misallocation.
So now that we understand the problem, how do we fix it?
How do we stop these smart, capable teams from making decisions that good for them?
Because they become profit centers and it looks good on their bottom line, they're bad for the business.
All right, so this isn't about policies or pricing then.
It's about our organizational design.
And we have three strategic levers that we can pull.
We have pricing incentives and decision rights.
Let's look at each one of these.
First up here, centralized transfer pricing.
Instead of letting divisions negotiate prices with each other, that can often lead to turf wars and inefficiencies, let's have corporate headquarters step in.
They can set a standard transfer price based on the opportunity cost of the asset.
In nextec's case, that means pricing the battery based on what the division could earn from external buyers, but on the value it creates internally for the device division.
This ensures that decisions are made based on what's best for the firm, not individual units.
Here we can look at opportunity cost based pricing.
This can be aligning with our economic theory.
The optimal price reflects the next best alternative, use of the resource, not arbitrary markups.
This keeps assets flowing to their highest value use and avoids the value destruction that happens when internal prices are distorted.
Next we look at compensation.
Right now, each division is paid based on its own profits.
That sounds kind of fair, right?
But in reality, what happens is it fuels competition between teammates.
What if instead, both the battery and devices division earn bonuses only if Next Tech's overall profit increase.
Suddenly the battery team cares if its pricing hurts product sales because it hits their bonus too.
This is a shift from local optimization to global alignment.
By tying performance metrics to firmwide outcomes, stuff like total profit, stock price or key performance indicators, we encourage cross division cooperation.
It's Basically Incentive Theory 101.
People do what they're paid to do.
You change the rewards and behavior will follow.
But, and again, this is important.
This approach can also dilute accountability.
If everyone is measured on a big shared number, some may coast while others carry the load.
That's known as a free free rider problem.
And it's a big risk.
So execution here matters.
We need performance metrics that balance individual impact with corporate success.
Third, and maybe the most radical fix here is reassign our decision rights.
What if the device's division was allowed to source batteries externally?
If the internal price wasn't competitive.
Now the battery division must price fairly or risk losing the deal.
So it's kind of like injecting a little external market discipline into internal decisions.
This approach doesn't require top down micromanagement.
It uses incentives and choice to push internal players towards value, maximizing behavior.
So this is some cosian logic.
Here we're going to look at a solution that involves cosian logic.
Whenever transactions cost inside the firm are higher than market alternatives, markets outperform hierarchies.
Given divisions the right to buy or sell externally when it makes sense disciplines inefficient pricing without corporate intervention.
All right, but beware here.
Too much autonomy can create fragmentation.
You risk losing scale advantages or create brand inconsistencies if every division operates like its own mini company.
So again, the solution only works when you've established clear boundaries, controls and strategic alignment.
Truth is here, there really is no silver bullet.
Each of these solutions has cost, has benefits, has trade offs, and the right choice depends on the company's size, structure, culture, etc.
So what are we looking at here?  Central pricing.
It's great for coordination, but can be rigid.
Shared incentives.
It fosters unity, but may demotivate top performers.
And decision rights empowers teams.
But it's a risky strategic drift.
So the key here is to view organizational design not as a static structure, but as a dynamic system.
Here, this is one where pricing and incentives and authority evolve together to support the firm's strategic goals.
Let's choose the right fix here.
All right, so we've already looked at three promising solutions here.
Centralized transfer pricing time pay to company wide performance and reassigning those decision rights to internal buyers.
In reality though, there's no one size fits all.
Now for our fast scaling tech firm, what we have to do is look at potential solutions.
But those solutions may not work with a giant conglomerate.
And so we have to look at this from a firm level and then take a look at the trade offs that are involved.
Now let's look at transfer centralized transfer pricing first.
We know that it offers clarity and consistency.
No more battles over who's charging what.
We're just standardized in internal price based off of opportunity costs.
Now this aligns decisions with what's best for the whole company.
It reduces conflict and lobbying between divisions.
And it ensures product flows at their highest value use.
But here's a downside.
Central pricing often depends on limited, biased or delayed information.
Headquarters might not fully understand any fast changing local conditions, especially in global or fast moving markets.
So this is a classic trade off between centralized authority and local knowledge as framed by Friedrich Hayek and later organizational theorists.
The more removed HQ is from transaction.
And so this is a classic trade off between centralized authority and local knowledge.
All right, so what we see here, the more removed HQ is from the transaction, the harder it becomes to set efficient prices.
Especially when internal players manipulate data to win favorable terms.
So if your corporate center isn't equipped with real time trustworthy data, you might be centralizing the illusion of control, but no actual strategy.
Let's look at our second approach.
Tying bonuses to company wide results.
This is going to send a powerful message we can win together.
Pros here is that it encourages operational encourages cooperation across divisions.
It reduces turf wars and destructive internal competition.
And it aligns division behavior with shareholder value.
But we have to watch out for this thing called free riding.
If one division performs exceptionally well, while others under deliver, top performers may feel their hard work is diluted and unrewarded.
This is known as the multi agent problem.
In economics, when multiple agents are rewarded based on a shared outcome, individual effort becomes harder to monitor and less directly tied to the reward.
Over time, high performance may disengage or high performers may disengage unless the system includes differentiated performance signals.
So here, to succeed with shared incentives, you need a culture of mutual accountability, peer review and sometimes team based metrics that combine division results with cross functional goals.
Our last and third fix tier is giving internal buyers the right to choose external vendors.
Here this can be game changing for performance.
It injects market discipline into internal processes so we can see the pros and cons.
Keeps internal pricing honest, reduces our HQ intervention and encourages divisions to earn each other's business.
But this isn't risk free.
It allows internal buyers to get to the market.
And that can lead to fragmentation where brand consistency and data integration or innovation pipelines suffer.
So this returns to Coase's theory of the firm.
Firms exist because they can coordinate activities more efficiently than markets, but only when the transaction costs are lower inside than outside.
When you push too much decision making to the market, you may lose economies of scale, shared learning or brand coherence.
So what we look at with NexTech, if device division switches to an external battery supplier with slightly lower prices but inconsistent quality or product reliability, what we could see is that the device may begin to decline, its quality may begin to decline and that could damage the company's reputation.
So this solution really works best when products are modular and supply markets are mature and internal divisions are held to competitive standards.
All Right.  So let's make a right choice and look at a strategic fit here.
So ultimately the best solution depends on what our strategic priorities are.
If we're optimizing for efficiency and alignment, then centralized transfer pricing may work.
If our top priority is collaboration and culture, shared incentives might be the best option.
If we operate in fast moving markets, flexible decision rights might unlock the speed and innovation that we need.
This reflects what organizational economists call the contingency approach.
There is no universally best structure, only best fits the right architecture.
Depends on your business model, market conditions, technological complexity and cultural norms.
So don't just ask which fix is best, instead ask which trade offs can we live with?
And ask where's the real friction in our system?
And above all, design with intent.
Because the structure you choose will shape the behavior that you get.
So let's look at what happens.
We call it a lucky break.
Sometimes life throws you a lifeline.
Next Tech is now rebounding.
Looks very good, but what's taking place here?
Well, what we see is that global prices for batteries has skyrocketed.
And this is a lucky break for NexTech.
It's just dumb luck.
This is an actual solution.
This isn't an actual solution, it's just catching a break.
Numbers look good, but that might only happen for a quarter or two.
Nothing internal has changed and the underlying structure of Next Tech is remaining the same.
So what we see is incentives are still misaligned, transfer pricing was still political, and decision rights are still fuzzy.
Problem hasn't been solved, it's only been temporarily buried by this increase in price.
Economists call this a mass inefficiency when external events obscure internal flaws.
And so in behavioral terms, it's kind of an outcome bias.
That is the belief that because things turned out well, the decisions must have been good.
But in truth, structural mission, structural misalignment still lurk beneath the surface.
And once battery price is normalized, guess what's going to happen?
All these internal conflicts are going to come back.
And so we had no real fixes and no structural reform.
So let's break that down to what it really means.
Here we need to start clarifying our decision rights.
Who sets prices between divisions?
Who chooses suppliers?
And who controls product prioritization?
Ambiguity.
Ambiguity breeds conflict.
Clear decision rights ensure that responsibility matches the accountability in organizational design.
This is about aligning authority with incentives.
Decision rights should rest with the parties best positioned to act on the information, but only if their payoffs reflect the consequences of their decisions.
We can look at redesigning performance metrics if you want People to act differently, measure them differently, move away from isolated profit center metrics, and instead adopt key performance indicators that capture true economic value creation.
All right, so some examples here include net contribution to the firmwide, I can never pronounce that.
Ebitda, internal customer satisfaction metrics, and joint bonus pools across upstream and downstream teams.
This addresses what system thinkers call sub optimization.
When individual components of a system optimize themselves at the expense of the whole.
Redesigning the performance metrics Fosters goal congruence, I.e.
aligning local behavior with goal, with global objectives.
And then here, lastly, look at redefining organizational boundaries.
Sometimes we just don't need to tweak the rules.
Sometimes we need to redraw the lines.
Here, organizational restructuring comes in.
NexTech could convert the better division into a call center for internal transfers, consolidate devices and battery into a single informed team focused on product lines, or create cross functional value streams with end to end accountability.
So these are examples of what Galbraith called organizational differentiation and integration.
As companies grow more complex, they need new structures to manage internal independence.
So informed structures in particular work well.
Well, when coordination across functions becomes a bottleneck, the real takeaway here is that structure drives behavior.
If your divisions are fighting over transfer prices or optimizing at each other's expense, you don't have a people problem, you have a design problem.
And design problems demand systemic solutions, not temporary wins.
So whether market shift or competitors evolve or prices fluctuate, a well designed organization doesn't just survive, it adapts and it aligns.
Once those two take place, it performs all right.
So we don't need to wait for luck to come around.
We need to make our divisions better by having to make better decisions given the system that we put in place.
Let's look at some key takeaways here.
So in business, we often celebrate the bold decision, right?
The brilliant product of the visionary leader.
But too often, we overlook the quiet force that shapes every result and every failure.
And that structure.
First, key takeaway is good people and bad system equals bad outcomes.
At NexTech, no one was trying to sabotage the company.
Each division was just doing what it thought was right.
Maximize its own, maximizing its own performance.
But with shared goals and structural alignment, even the smartest teams pull in the opposite direction.
Key takeaway here is great decisions don't happen by accident.
They happen by design.
Next, transfer pricing strategy.
How you price internally determines how resources flow, how divisions interact, and how your team defines success.
When transfer prices reward internal gatekeeping over external value creation, you're not just Distorting incentives, you're sabotaging your strategy.
So our key takeaway here.
Set prices that move assets to their highest valued use.
Next incentives shape culture.
Incentives don't just drive behavior.
They define the culture that you're in.
If people are rewarded for protecting their turf, they'll become territorial.
If people are rewarded for shared wins, they'll collaborate.
Key takeaway.
Pay people for outcomes that matter.
Next decision Rights drive speed and accountability.
If it's unclear who gets to decide, everything slows down.
But when rights and responsibilities are clearly mapped, teams are going to move fast and resolve conflict on the ground, and they're going to own those outcomes.  Key takeaway.
Push decisions to where the best information is last.
Build a resilient design.
Next Tech got lucky with the price increase.
Markets change, cost rise, competitors down.
The company that wins in the long run are those that structure, that create structures that align effort, speed, and purpose.
All right, so it doesn't matter what takes place in the market.
They are aligning everything together.
Key takeaway here.
Great companies are systems that turn coordination into competitive advantage.
So at NexTech, what we learned is that autonomy without alignment is chaos and that good divisions will only make good decisions when they're built into a system that rewards you for doing so.
So ask yourself this.
Are your divisions aligned with your strategy?
Are your metrics serving your mission?
And are your teams incentivized to act in the firm's best interest or just their own?
In the end, success is just about making the right call.
It's about building a company where every call is the right one by design.
And that's it.  Hope you've enjoyed it.